the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our broadcast of
the 2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster tatsav abrahamian and we get
to see the A and B groups of this
tournament uh of one being hotly
contested and the other one might even
be clinched today by Felix blauberger
hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of spring chess
classic it's possible as Julian
mentioned that we will Crown the
champion today so let's take a look at
the standings and see where we are going
into this round and we see in group a
the difference between the first place
and last place is actually only one
point so this is a very tightly
contested group so we have a three-way
tie as we did yesterday there is no
change in the standings there is Foods
Christopher you and Benjamin Park going
to this round tight for first place and
a tie between four players some Savion
ilionic Benjamin gladora norderbeck
yakuboya who are half a point behind and
then we have three players Daniel Darda
yasur quesada and ABI Mishra who are
only a point behind so anything still
can happen in this tournament so it's
possible that anyone can still win this
so we will find out what happens today
and tomorrow when we will Crown at
finally a champion and in the big group
actually things are very different as we
have one player Felix blauberger who won
his game yesterday in first place with
five and a half points being chased by
Jason Liang who is a full point behind
and for third place we have a tie
between number three and batiran and
akshat Chandra and um this one I
actually might have a winner today
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
tournament format
the players are playing game and 90 with
a 30 second increment from starting move
1 and then at move 40 they will get an
additional 30 minutes for the rest of
the game with 30 second increment
throughout the entire game and the
schedule is um they will be playing
today at 1pm 1pm obviously but tomorrow
they'll start two hours earlier and this
is because there might be a playoff so
join us two hours earlier at um
uh 2 p.m Central Standard Time
so there are already several hours into
their games
and let's take a look at the pairings
and let's see what is going on in this
round so let's start with group a
and uh
we have our key matchup of the day which
is between Christopher you and Sam
Serbian as the two co-leaders and we
will jump to that game but uh we because
the Run has started at one o'clock there
are a lot of positions that we might be
having decisive results on so let's
start with this game and then we'll move
on to the other positions
and looking at this my first impression
is that this game is actually
nearing a draw but maybe it's a bit
dangerous for
a white because maybe this Pond will
fall so if we imagine this King coming
close then Bishop F1 and maybe rerunning
this bishop but I think if that happens
then white will start checking the king
and then King moves away then we'll come
back to B1 and defend this so I think
maybe this game is Just nearing a draw
at this point so I know that 4v3s are
are tip are typically theoretically
drawn but maybe practically difficult to
play do you uh have any experience
experience with 5v4s and what the
evaluation of those positions usually
are not that black will get a 5V board
but he is dreaming of achieving that one
day maybe I don't think I've ever had it
in the game
end games and of course the more pawns
we add the better it is for the site
who's trying to win and in that position
there are better chances of course for
black and especially here because
immediately we can create a past pawn
and can be quite annoying and also will
depend on the structure if my Rook can
get let's say on the second rank cut off
your king so five versus four is already
very difficult to defend of course
there's always practical chances in a
Rogan game but I don't think we will get
there because
and so the way he played as we said this
moves Bishop C6 of course it's
impossible to take the Rook is hanging
so he defends and now I imagine
something like this so let's say
we bring our Kings
so the King goes back and something like
this and I will check
yeah so there's never going to be an
opportunity for me to put three pieces
on the B5 Pawn
and I think what maybe we can do is play
something like this and put a king on B6
so for example something like this now
this is a threat
so let's say you check I go here
and now I can bring a rook from this
side so this actually can become a bit
uncomfortable
but in the game instead he played F4
in this position and now King E7
so perhaps his idea is not to bring his
King but to do what maybe to activate
his rook and put a rook on A6 yeah
actually you can move your Rook away
right right now as white because Bishop
B5 would would be tactically impossible
due to Rook to B1 yes I believe
I think still very good drawing chances
but okay why allow any of this so in
this position then I would play here uh
but I'm still worried about this move
because I think you are very likely to
lose this Pawn actually I think you are
losing the spawn so it's just a matter
of creating some kind of counter play
here and maybe getting one of the king
side Pawns
but I don't see that happening so I
think this position is already becoming
a bit problematic
so Sam is going to be pressing against
Christopher in this end game for maybe a
while do you want to take a look at um
some of the other games
uh let's take a look yes at this game
which I thought was going to have a
results on Benjamin glitter and Darius
Swartz and we see that black is in a lot
of trouble
and Rook G5 is coming a huge threat
and the question is what to do here this
position actually if we just do a recap
of what's going on in the position so
Rook versus two pieces but the two
pieces are on the queen side and the
king is just very lonely and getting
checkmated so if it's black to move what
can black do here
so root T5 is a thread so The Rook on A5
I want to put it to use but
unfortunately we cannot capture it
because now we bring another piece into
the game right which leads to immediate
checkmate
and otherwise
um so if we play a move like F4
it doesn't look good but I I gotta try
something
say take
okay
if you go to rookie five I will take or
rain I guess Bishop E6 is my only chance
and maybe somehow things are defended
here so if I check in I also saw the
eval job
um immediately dropped so if I check and
annoying who everything is defended
because if I take here you'll take with
the King and this is defended by the
Knight
so that doesn't really work out for me
so F4 is a very
logical trial let's see what we can do
here
so I cannot avoid this trade I don't
think E5 is anything right you will just
take
yeah
um
no but you cannot take
oh yes I have some oh I lose a piece
yeah okay so if I go E5 still
threatening Rook G5 what uh will you do
hmm
it's a tough it's a tough question maybe
a bishop Bishop E6
oh yeah yeah the other the other threat
so the main thread here is actually uh
Rook G5 I don't think Queen H7 is what
devastating
so maybe
a three-way time yeah the the a group
like as you said before anybody can win
this tournament and
um yeah it must be really tense right
now for all the players nobody nobody
wants to give up their current spot in
the standings and
buyers we see
and we can actually if we go back here
this tactic that happened black played
this move Knight C6 which looks very
logical right your opponent is attacking
the pawn and you're defending
but again
we see this lonely King with no
Defenders and immediately Knight F6 just
destroying the position
and then the Rook on H4 with a
devastating idea of Queen h6o Checkmate
and it must be said that black must take
on F6 because if you played King h8 then
Rook H4 was force Checkmate I believe
Rook H4 and if um you play H6 then you
can play Rook H6 gh6 Queen H6
this is just game I wanted to take with
the queen but I don't think that works
out
oh yeah yeah then G7 Square
unfortunately
that's unfortunate okay
okay and then you block yeah because if
you go King G5 I have mate ah that would
be that would be very pretty also I have
many ways to meet
must be very satisfying right right
Bishop F5 unfortunately saves Black's
life
but so gf6 so this is played now Queen
H6 is coming so Rook 8 only move Queen
H6 so he plays F5 and this really
beautiful move Bishop before which is
probably what he missed with the point
being that uh you cannot take only four
with the pawn as we showed before this
is hanging so Queen H7 here
and queen F7 made because by taking a
bishop View
introduced your opponents his into the
attack and if black passes somehow let's
say Rook A5 then there's this mobile
Rook G4 oh man and after F takes G4
Bishop H7
all right
too yeah
yeah I wanted to show because this is a
very common thing right just Bishop the
bishop and the queen right you don't
even get her Rook on F1 anymore
and it would it would be nicer if you
could take the Rook on F1 off the board
and then you just your opponent has all
the pieces and you just checkmate with
the pieces that would have been very
satisfying so I think Bishop B4 is the
move he possibly missed and so he took
with the Rook but the problem is all
again this uh heavy piece positions
right and the King safety this team that
keeps coming up yeah this king is quite
Lonely No Defenders if this bishop could
transport itself to G7 this king would
be red and black would probably just be
winning
well maybe maybe not because Black's
cane is still pretty weak but
it would at least be a fight
no there's all these ideas with queen H7
it takes A5 F6 so Rook A5 bringing a
piece into the defense but now after
Rook H5
so black is still thinking uh a really
nice attack a bit of him I can call it
the miniature so over 20 moves but a
really nice attack by white so we expect
to have a decisive result in the game
and in the meantime let's take a look at
the pairings in group b
and there as we mentioned
we have one player who is a point ahead
so Felix blauberger is a full point
ahead of his closest rival Jason Liang
and um there I happen to be playing
today with Felix with the white pieces
and Jason with the black pieces so let's
go up to that game and see what we have
there yeah and if I'm not mistaken if
Felix wins this game then the tournament
the term is just over he's he's won the
tournament clear first with a round
despair
yeah that would be very impressive and
very satisfying result of course winning
such a strong tournament with a run to
spare so what is your first impression
of this position
um I do like I do like black here
because I think the bishop on G2 is is
blunted and I'm not sure what the queen
on A6 is doing at the moment but on the
other hand I have seen positions like
this where white can play a move like G4
at some point and then the center
collapses I mean now would be a really
bad time to do it but uh
I don't know probably I prefer black but
not by not by a whole lot
yeah when I first look at the position I
actually didn't even realize that white
is up upon
this is you mentioned
the soul out of the game
um like why is the queen here what is it
doing there and blocks play actually
this piece play can be quite easy what
is um what is blackplay actually
associated with because I'm realizing I
cannot go afford the pawn is hanging as
you mentioned we don't want to move
these pawns because we're planting this
bishop can we say we're blunting is it
correct I believe so
and there's some kind of a peace
domination right because this Knight
also
being nominated and this uh two Bishops
aiming on this side at some point I
would like to be able to win this pawn
and this queen at the same time the
screen is kind of annoying right because
if I go Rook A8 then you take my Pawn I
know you're quite happy because you will
also take the C pawn and you get a pass
Pawn I wonder if I can play a call move
like Bishop C7 just with the intention
of playing Rook A8 and taking the A2
Pawn back
um so if I go here so actually you're
threatening to trap my no you're not
threatening to trap my game but I I
don't want my queen going to be seven I
was just thinking if I go here yeah but
now your queen doesn't have any squares
yeah I'm actually trapped so I have to
go to A3
so Rook here I go I don't I only have
three moves uh you can go to C3 right
button you don't want to run into Bishop
E5 I guess
so
do you want to be five or you want to
take with the threat of Bishop P5 as we
say thread is stronger than the
execution
yeah Rook A2 seems like a better move
it's probably a transposition because
here
is this trapping my queen again no I
have C1
but like the quality of Black's pieces
is obviously better than the quality of
White's pieces I think the one advantage
that white has um is uh with the
structure on the king side like I think
even though our pawns
um are currently blunting the bishop on
G2 if at some point white can undermine
them with either G4 or F3 uh maybe
Black's pawns become isolated and weak
later in the game so the White's playing
for long-term advantages in black is
playing for activity right now
so at least the blog has sorry white has
a pawn for his suffering right so it's
not like my queen is out of the game My
Bishop is not doing anything and I have
nothing to show for it yeah but as we
kept mentioning the long-term potential
right so pun structure so whenever we're
going
um
foreign
structure you want to go for the core of
the structure so here is F5 which is why
Julian keeps mentioning this move
because once we take this E4 Pawn would
be quite happy
so I think black really wishes this Pawn
was on G6 and this Knight or somewhere
else to keep the structure so let's move
Rook D7
sorry I
let me promote this so Bishop H6 and
Rook one to D7 offering an exchange so
what do we think about this move
I think it makes a lot of sense a rook
D7 trying to uh get the open D file if
white trades on D7 I think that's that's
beneficial to us
um who's us uh who are we in this case
actually I don't know we're on the
winning side but this game is a bit
double-edged so I don't know it was us
here just speaking from Black's
perspective I think Eric D7 and queen D7
would be would be good for would be good
for black a good exchange because the
the queen controls the D file although
maybe not because Knight E3 or D1 could
also could also come
um yeah I'm not actually so sure about
this exchange because
uh what movie are suggesting Bishop C7
which I like is now Rook A8 is a big
threat right but once we take this Rooks
off the board my queen finally feels
safer on A6 because I don't think you
can really attack it right because
you're attacking with a rook before but
now your Rook is not connected to anyone
so this is not an option and your V6
Pawn is hanging so after 93 Rook D1 how
do you take advantage of my queen being
so awkwardly placed yeah that's that's a
that's a pretty good question I'm not
entirely sure but maybe yeah something
something like C4 uh not even playing
against your queen but just getting the
past Pawn could be could be pretty
interesting
so E3 was plate uh so I don't I don't
like that move personally yeah I don't
like it either because it
it does several things so first this
idea of F3 becomes more difficult and it
also takes away a square from the Knight
so now the Knight is also a bit trapped
so now you actually don't have any moves
with the Knight
because our Hope was to play we wanted
to trade right 93 with the idea of Rook
D1 right and this is actually not a move
right because maybe I even have Queen
Ace oh j7 is defended
got very excited there
I mean still like black needs to be
worried about his King because
um if he's not careful we do control the
seventh rank even Queen I think Queen A7
is a it's a perfectly logical move and
Rook D1 could you oh you're you're
trading off like my active Queen but
still like takes and Rick D1 wow I think
white is actually for Choice here
because now we can see that the the
pawns on the on the king side for black
will become quite weak
um even Bishop H3 instead of G4 oh
because there's no way to defend them
yeah I actually like white here
um and we keep saying this uh uh sorry
if um Felix blauberger wins then he will
win the tournament but if Jason wins
then it's a whole different story Jason
will tie for first and
um if he wins tomorrow then he also has
chances to win the tournament outright
and I think
I think going into the next round still
a point ahead so I don't think he feels
too much pressure to win this game and
uh even though he's not playing for any
Norms or anything there is uh quite a
large price fund for this tournament so
there's a lot on the line for them to
play because
winning this tournament would be a nice
paycheck yeah let's go ahead and look at
the price one what are the players
playing for
so in group a first place is six
thousand four thousand and three
thousand for first through third and the
total price fund is 22 000 so quite a
bit of money in group a and in group b
first place is four thousand twenty five
hundred and two thousand for first
through third and with a total price
fund of fourteen thousand dollars so
definitely no Small Change there which
is why I feel like since Jason are are
going to be fighting their hardest in
this game and it's a fifteen hundred
dollar difference between first and
second place which is significant so the
first place would be would be preferable
so for sure E3 and Jason does have more
time on the clock and another thing that
really bothers me here is this C Pawn
because the C Pawn might move so I see
he made a move I don't know what the
move is yet
197 so he decides he's not happy with
his Knight on G6 he brings it back I
wonder if he's thinking about Queen H5
so this bishop is kind of funny here but
at least we have that Foursquare so this
is what I was going to say I think
um in the previous position uh when
black had an iron G6 white doesn't
really want to play the move Bishop F4
because we will play Knight F4 and I
think the two Bishops are actually an
advantage here but now that Knight E7 is
played as Bishop F4 a good idea because
if you play Bishop F4 it can take with
my pawn and once again put my knight on
on the E3 Square uh I am I running into
something
I think I would wait for you to make me
play Bishop F4 because if you want 97 so
what is the idea of 97 I think you want
to go to D5 right because I don't think
he played 97 with the idea of Queen G6 I
don't because I don't it's not like
you're trapping the bishop doesn't seem
like a huge threat so if I go here maybe
takes takes 95 can be annoying wait
actually maybe I should take on D7 first
before I take on F4 because
um I think the more pieces I trade just
the better it is for me I I'm a pawn
after all no
but now I'm a little if it takes I'm I'm
a bit afraid here I'm afraid too but but
it's not your game yeah it's not my game
I can take my moves back yeah how do you
like Queen four oof I want to play
Bishop F1 yeah Bishop F1 might save you
because otherwise everything is just
hanging here right
55.
[Music]
1 yeah everything is sort of hanging but
yeah I think you have to be like very
concrete to make sure everything works
so let's go for this forcing line right
you have to take uh I'm sure you don't
like to take Queen A7 which is what I
thought I was gonna do
so now I have to go
one of these moves
um but I don't like this for you but
it's really nice for a K8 comes yeah I
miss this idea me too I just had two
squares to choose from
not this one uh
yeah so okay let's go for this you take
take so now this is hanging so you go
back otherwise you'll run into this so I
go here this Pond makes me really
nervous because if you think about the
ponds right so it's four four versus
three here and this is two versus two
but this past one it's a defended fast
Pawn which is really dangerous and I'm
winning this Pawn which might mean I
might win this one
that's true but I don't actually know
like rookie rookie one you have to take
with your knight right because Bishop
takes runs into Rook a two and ship C4
so
um when you take with your knight I go
Knight E3 I I do agree that black has
like a lot of play but I think white
also has Play Because F5 becomes quite
weak and yeah I just want to oh yeah
actually just threatening to take it so
if I make
if I go here you can take it that's
that's fancy uh but I'm also okay I
don't want to pin my pin myself because
something like this or Knights of Knight
C4 with Knight V6 might be
trouble
I shouldn't I was just trying to make a
move let me make
a move
just to show
Julian is trying to do okay that's a
fair point and actually we're getting a
lot of moves in so Bishop F4 was played
he didn't trade on D7 first so takes
takes a knight D5 understandably he
didn't want to have all his pieces
hanging into Knife Works
so 93 and uh it's nice to be a huge
threat or you take on D7 but okay let's
try to find the move actually Rook A6 is
a big threat here this is the main
thread you're trying to trap my queen so
I have to come back this is my only move
right yeah I mean you can't go to A4
Knight C3 has to be really good after
Queen A4
what is this called The Royal Fork uh
or that has things I think it has to
include the game but I'm really bad with
chestnomenclature I couldn't tell you
it's just cultural I think it's just
this names that like I don't think we
have this in other languages Maybe
okay Queen A3 played but I also think
this is very good for white because
everything is forced now in his low on
time and when you're alone time you
really want to get a lot of moves in
especially with increment because then
you're just building time so when you
play you know when you play a move like
Bishop F4 in your opponent takes it's a
free move for you so that's uh you get a
move you get closer to move 40 and you
get 30 seconds added to your clock so
there is no downside to something like
this and the reason I'm saying this is
because he has nine and a half minutes
and Jason has 25 minutes and there is
still a lot of moves to make and the
position is not that simple as we see
right a position is very complicated I
mean on every turn both well first of
all in in real life the bar is going you
know up and down and and secondly I mean
we try to play some moves and uh
it's just so easy to make a mistake
and now I'm starting to think that the
queen is coming to B2 how do I feel
about this King here
hard to imagine how this king would come
on on trouble but uh you know not the
Kink seems a little more vulnerable
without the dark squared Bishop because
if I compare this position to this
not this we do it like this where
there's a bishop here but I also have
you know my dark squared Bishop so my
king feels better defended but after all
of this which is an E3 Bishop F4 now I
understand the idea initially I didn't
really understand the purpose but now I
see he wants to trade on them for the
Knight only three
I'm starting to wonder uh about the
safety of this I'm wondering if Knight
E7 just ran into the idea of e3 though
like I think that uh black might have
been better off just not moving his
knight from G6 like his Bishop F4
release something that white wants to do
so he has to make a different move here
than instead of 97 well 97 was played
after E3 right so E3 and then instead of
97 I I don't know what an improve like
what a good improving move like uh maybe
bishop C7 again or queen yeah sure Queen
F7 like if you play Bishop F4
I think I just take it with my knight
right like this this position doesn't
feel like it should be very good for
white like EF and then Bishop D4 even
like position looks like domination yeah
because if you take this quality of the
pawns again yeah controlling the center
is important in chess
oh yeah Bishop F4 wasn't really an idea
but you're right 97 kind of encouraged
this move so I think they're making more
moves what I see on the feed
so 95 280 Rook pd8 all of this very
logical
so Knights and Rooks and we see this
pieces eyeing each other so now we have
to worry about night jumps because uh
Knights are very annoying pieces for
example if I go Queen C1 yeah Knight of
four or four yeah it's kind of cool
maybe you were even threatening Knight
F4 in the initial position because like
yeah Knight F4 you take on D7 I go
Knight E2 and then Kane F1 I take on D7
with the queen and then when you take on
E2 I have Queen D2 check
well Queen Victoria run away I think you
want to start with well okay
yeah you you're meaner than me you
actually want to Checkmate your opponent
I just wanted to win my piece back who
said this was it uh Chris chickens like
if you win in the middle game you don't
have to worry about the end game anymore
so if you check with your opponent then
you don't have to worry about endgames
that's Fair
so Queen A3 Rook be dead Okay so Knight
F4 is a threat so Knight F4 is a threat
because of 92 so we have to cover it too
so if I go here
is this oh am I running into okay but
let's try this again yeah I defended my
knight yeah
let's say here
here we take with the queen don't think
you want to take with the pawn but now I
can just win a pawn right right and then
black has the better structure in this
end game because you have a you have a
protected past pawn and
um unlike in previous positions where we
had this G4 lever I think now playing G4
weekends our own structure because we
have these dub we'll have these double
isolated F Pawns
okay so let's find a move here
so Knight F4 this card is a threat
Bishop F1 is maybe an idea because if
there's no 92 I don't think Knight F4
works very well
and any kind of check will be met with
Queen G3 so I'm going to worry about
there
okay
uh so now we're are we threatening
Bishop C4 I'm still a bit worried about
this my Rook is a bit loose here and
there's this Knight C3 in there so I'm a
bit nervous can I play
here with the idea of going to seven
Knights of three somehow the queen B2
just to get on the diagonal
also the queen on A3 makes me a little
worried yeah I'm not thrilled about the
queen there
clean up someone looks like a normal
move right it's threatening some Rook
a7s maybe put a queen on G7
yeah you still probably go Queen G7
right Queen G7 then take take and we
have to still be thinking about some
Knight C3 tricks
maybe maybe Knight C3 is even a threat
right now taking day to pawn yeah I
think in this end game the black one
state to pawn white is in a lot of
trouble
so Bishop F1 plate
so uh Felix flanked pretty quickly I
didn't have minutes so he made this move
in 30 seconds
so that's quite quick and um it feels
like with every move
um this position is just so imbalanced
that like the level of danger changes
it's like okay well that's why I do but
that's black too that's why I do I
wonder how they feel
about this position maybe we can talk to
one of them or both of them and talk
about these critical moments in the game
and how they're feeling here
yeah definitely very tense right now a
lot of money on the line and every
decision is is very tough for both
players
and uh so in this section we have a
result already Kirk azarian through I
want to go to the final position apology
took apati so this was a some kind of a
repetition
18 move draw which is not allowed in
this tournament unless you achieve it
through repetition so these these
players
um had to play three moves to in order
to claim a draw because there's a 40
move drawable
Queen B3 and then you block into
Discovery yeah seven it's not very
natural
so all of this happened I wonder so
they're following a game which I always
wonder when I see these sorts of names
it seems like it should be a
correspondence game to me probably yeah
and now we see the repetition
but Kirk is having a pretty tough
tournament he's at -2 so I think he just
wants to um you know a hill what did
they say stop the bleeding
and be done with this and another game
that we saw were were expecting to see
results soon there was a really nice
tactic I will show that moment here this
game which is actually Chandra and
dumbassar and batsurin a really nice
unexpected shot of Bishop H7 because the
Rooks are not connected yet the idea
being that after King 87 Queen H4 picks
up the Rook
you have one of our uh Saint Louis very
famous St Louis Grandmasters of kovi and
says loose pieces drop off this is like
favorite saying so Rook on d8 is not
protected by anything you gotta watch
out for tactics like this and this is
the correct move order we're looking at
this before the broadcast because Queen
H4
which looks even more threatening
because you take on H7 what a queen is
met by Bishop F5
both blocking this bishop and connecting
the Rooks so this was the
gripe my water
and now I also don't love this yeah
empty it but
it's just a white uh upper Pawn on the
compensation right because you also have
the salmon rank you also positionally
worse this is um pretty big blunder by
the black player it should be six and
takes another Pawn
and I think he wanted to go Bishop E6
just to finish his development but I
think here rookie 6 is possible
at least okay you're trading but at
least you finish your development yeah
maybe he was afraid of even like Queen
D4 here or I identity a B4 looks good
but I was thinking this end game is just
like flat out unplayable like you have
the you have the worst Bishop you're
down a pawn and you have no entry
squares so I will dominate the one of
the files and I'll bring my cane in
slowly and I think you just lose yeah
this is there's nothing good about this
position
so he won Bishop B6 takes on B7
oh this is like a very similar tactic oh
this is tough um but I mean the position
was already so bad so I don't think I
can blame him for that that's nice it's
nice geometry but it's the same Rook
right that comes under this attack this
Rook that one from d8 to some adventures
and the idea being if you take which is
uh what happened in the game check and
picks up this Rook
and now Rook V1 simply defends the pawn
puts the Rook behind the pawn and then
at some point this point will start
moving so okay four but okay this game
will go on for some time I don't think
um
I mean I don't see any counter play for
black maybe he wants to play something
like Rook H4 but also it's going to take
some time for white to push the spawn
and make progress
but uh this will go on for a few more
moves and our most our most combative
player in this tournament Victor
mikhalevsky
uh he did lose that game yesterday that
um
that Queen it was Queen versus bishop
and a rook right and then became Queen
eventually yeah he lost that game
and the position looks extremely
complicated yeah it's on A6 and A5 and
that's not something we're used to
seeing a lot of things are happening
here the position is just wild so black
has black has the center
um but white has this uh this pass Pawn
on C6 which could be very dangerous and
this bishop on G2 which could also be
very strong just hanging right just
looks like you know when you like take
your uh your pieces out of your bag and
you dump them on the board this is sort
of what the position looks like to me
and we'll definitely come back to this
game because it just looks fascinating
and interesting but in group a we're
nearing the result in this game between
Benjamin glador and Darius Spirits going
to promote this so we'll see how we got
here
so this is where we left off F6 is
played of course now the movie is happy
with so Queen takes
and the idea of uh so this looks strong
as well as Queen h8 possibly
Rook 135 Our Queen G6 with the idea for
K8 and you can not really go here
because I take yeah
all the pieces hang
and you're just mated but he actually
did go there because
because you don't have any other move
yeah it's a huge threat and Rook age
seven two
many too many threads here so King U7
take on F6 King D6 H7 our queen queen D6
right and I think this is game over I
think he resigned here wow really nice
really nice game
yeah from start to finish just a
dominating performance by Ghidorah and
if we get him here for interview we'll
talk about this game more because they
followed
um a game I believe it was by Fabiano
to a point so we see a lot of the
preparation in group a uh and uh you
know players following
finding Novelties on muftory like
Benjamin and so you know they're very
well prepared so if we do get him we'll
ask him about it if not we can come back
and take a look at it and let's see if
we have anything in Christopher you and
some Savion oh we do have five versus
four
oh man my question gets gets to be
answered but this is very different
right because F7 is hanging so you are
going to lose a pawn here so for example
so this was the position so even Rook A7
and he won King D3 which means he's not
worried about giving up this Pawn I
think the word the reason he's not
worried about giving up this point is
because after Rookie of seven this Pawn
Falls it's it's interesting that he
gives Rook B3 check probably he just did
this to get closer to the time control
right because you have to
eventually have your Rook take the H2
Pawn otherwise it's just going to be
rook and four versus rook and four right
yeah because okay Rook P3
this is bad
so you check me okay yeah this would be
a funny mate
no you're right I think he is simply
reaching um
we are reaching move 40 and
and this is the whole purpose of this
check but uh so let's see so
if check here King D3
takes King F7 should we give up the F
Pawn or should we give up the G Pawn oh
you don't you don't want to I I I mean I
want to achieve a pass pawn and I feel
like it's easier to do that if I play
f6e5 Then by keeping Emoji upon I'm not
totally sure how do you defend this guy
that's a good question
because okay if you go something like
this I just take I defend G3 and if you
go G6 I play Rook G7 right and if I go
G5 then you'll just take a lot and then
play all right well I mean in the
previous position but eventually you
will achieve the same position yeah
seven
yeah maybe black has to give away his G
Pawn in order to in order to play like
E5 and play for activity but I don't or
I meant like I mean earlier probably you
don't want to trade so many pawns if
we're trying to win like
in this position play E5
but I don't I don't foresee this being
super cool okay so let's say takes takes
takes and maybe four
yeah something like this
so King C3
and uh yeah maybe we can go
something like this right and then try
to go after this Pawn
um
so let's keep looking at the games we
are going to get an interview with
cladora so
um in this position we have the game
between ABI Mishra and
and Benjamin Park and Benjamin Bach is
one of the leaders in the tournament
and if he wins this round then he will
become the sole leader
so let's see what we have going on in
this position we can take the evaluation
and so if we look at the position again
we have the structure of first four
versus three and four versus three on
the queen side but so White's idea is to
create some kind of attack with G4 G5 as
the last move Rook H1 indicates and
Black's idea is to
play on The Queen side where the
majority is and black does have the two
Bishops and we talked a lot about
the advantage of the two Bishops and
also
controlling this e-file and we will come
back into this game but in the meantime
we have Benjamin gildura who won this
really beautiful game and is now leading
the tournament so congratulations on
your Victory we really enjoyed looking
at this game thank you so much so can
you please take us to this game
yeah so I played C4 which is
it was a surprise that is for him
because I play Knight f3d for E4 but in
this tournament I played see for the
first time
so he went E5 twice which I was
expecting that G3
yeah so the line is very interesting
United States Bishop G2 C6
uh he didn't play this before I mean I I
didn't know that he was going to play
this but I knew this so Knight F3
e494 Queen B6
9b3
A5
this is not the main line but definitely
one of the best foreplay
why it should know it very well if
if there is anything I'm not even sure
if it's an advantage so the trapping
your knight here yeah D3
A4 so was all of this still your
preparation yeah yeah it was done to
move uh
17. so now this 92 Bishop C5 Castle
E3 is very good move there stairs H1 9g4
963 and here I knew that Knight F2 is a
move and Rook have two Bishop of two
Knight F4 and
I know that yeah
I believe Knight takes A4
sorry yeah oh okay and how would you
evaluate this position so anyway it's
slightly better for a ride but I believe
it can be very unpleasant for black
because let's say queen A7
I'm not sure but
yeah there is some I have also some
development advantage and
yeah the nights are coming fast
four something like that
it's very unpleasant to play so he
played crasso which was the best move
94 D5 very important move otherwise life
would have been a huge trouble
cd5
and yeah Bishop C1 so why is D5 an
important move if um so I've also this
is just another one let's say I develop
a piece
yeah now I believe the A4 assignment but
I think the point is that if you will be
software C1 immediately green silver 93
then there is C5
and it ruins the the night
so that's why D5 is yeah
so 1945
Bishop C1 queen c193 and I knew that
there was a game
Switzerland oh yeah maybe okay so so
Corona this was 2019
um Singapore cup yeah I remember the
swizzler game
which was Rook F3
X id5
green D2 I wasn't sure about Bishop G4 I
didn't recall that
what to do after Bishop G4
but the IRS Amazon
Eed and
uh I wasn't sure if I have an advantage
here
so where do you think your advantage is
is it more against these people or
playing against this King somehow so
both both playing on both sides so you
want to take on something like Knight C6
yeah but I wasn't completely sure if
this is
yeah yeah you have quite a few so after
official G4 I can also play other moves
I have to
Rook have fun or Rook F2 even
because Rook have to have five Rook f
uck
yeah I was actually seen him D4 that's a
possibility I believe before here yeah
and then point being if takes you take
everything and then a g for your
standard queen a four check
but I wasn't home so used to sure if
it's an advantage but the idea of
looking for I have some initiatives yeah
yeah this looks quite dangerous because
looking at this position even what
happened in the game it didn't seem like
somehow it could be so dangerous for
bikes so right uh so when when were you
out of preparation so you said you know
so it is right it was the first move
and I remember that
there was a game
with 90 seminar I believe instead of
Queen d8
and 95 cd5 Knight C3
this is very similar to what you had in
the game night of circus
and I can start on F6
and
yeah this is
this is what I remembered
yeah and you would be satisfied with
this position right it takes and again I
mean I knew that it's a slight Advantage
for white and usually this you've
strange sacrifices are very unpleasant
so yeah I would definitely have gone for
this
so he played green date
I believe he is still new with this
because he played it very fast
natural and maybe he was out of book at
this point I wasn't sure
he played 97 it was watching her tapes
stairs Knight C3
and I was respect the United States
[Music]
what are you going to take again
I wasn't completely sure about this
[Music]
I was playing planning to roll E4
instead of Queen F4
and something like this I don't have
like an immediate attack but I have a
good I have good compensation
because of the wicking and you're yeah I
think I can see the future you have a
postpone as well exactly yeah so a lot
of your ideas are associated with the
sacrifice on F6 but instead it's funny
you did sacrifice on F6 so in the best
possible scenario so he went D4 and then
Knight D5
[Music]
what was your reaction when you saw this
move I mean I I was thinking about this
before he played D4
uh it looks very natural to offer this
day for 95.96 but on the other hand I
saw that I have Knight F6 which looked
extremely dangerous
I'm sure that he expected that but maybe
he didn't see
be sure before
yeah that's what we thought he missed
because rookie 8 Queen H6 F5 and this is
just such a beautiful move so what was
his reaction when he played this move
before
but uh yeah definitely this looks very
unpleasant because
I not only threatened Bishop there's F5
but also ruji for his
an idea of under threat
so that's why you have to take there was
no other move
do you think A5
yeah I was expecting this
group F3 I don't know what that is
oh the computer line
um I think the idea is to take on F5 and
not allow check first so kind of a
passing move but I think what you played
is more logical because yeah just I
think made
yeah it was our friend
I mean I know that the engine says like
plus series but
it didn't look so obvious to me like
after grenade green H7 cleaner fit
like after Rook H6
there are so many moves for blacklight
I don't have like an immediate threat
maybe rule G6 is I mean I was I was
planning to play Ruby series but
uh I was like black history
I was expecting that but then green G7
and then of course and then Queen G6
for example can show this
when's the queen so what was the move
that worried you the most
so I actually realized that Blacklist
just completely lost okay yeah because
we saw you on the screen and you look
like you're calculating really hard and
he looked kind of despondent because I
think he was also realizing that he's
losing so he must have had this some
point at this point probably already
thought everything that like I don't
have like an immediate threat it's
grenade you can always go clean
with seven and
maybe that is still losing but like it's
not an immediate win and
but yeah it's very hard hard to defend
Ruby suits and he played Rookery five
after Queen G5 yeah it's just completely
lost because I have to indices which is
very important yeah so you stop the king
from running and
now it's game over and you win this game
yeah and so now this puts you in the
first place so your closest Rivals are
Christopher and some Savion so this game
were likely to end in a draft so be
three-way tie and Benjamin bug was half
a point ahead so what do you think about
this position yeah I think he has some
chances to win so what it would be
Black's plan in this position
wait The Rook just went to H1 and then
it came back I thought his idea of this
Pawn was hanging that's where he came
back
um
well I think it's just some long term
like Bishop there I don't know if some
in this series I don't know which should
be seven
yeah
I don't know but it definitely looks
very good for black
and who do you play tomorrow I play ball
oh you play both so this might be a
championship game so if he wins then
you're in a must win position so you
will be with the black pieces you must
have a lot of experience playing for him
because you're Webster graduate yeah I
think I played him four times what's
your score against him or drawers all
draws okay yeah every time I play Black
summer again okay yeah he's a very rich
player yeah I respect is just a lot yeah
that is why he's winning the tournament
or they didn't
so yeah I I expected would fight
are you did you graduate from Webster
are you I'm going to graduate this may
oh this may okay well uh congratulations
on your
upcoming graduation so we'll be looking
forward to your game tomorrow for
fighting for the championship thank you
and that was Benjamin corduro winning
his game against the Dodger suite and
lip fracking came on taking the leads in
a tournament and we were looking at this
game between Mishra and Benjamin Park
where our guest was also thinking that
Black's position is better and black is
enjoying a nice Advantage associated
with this bishop pair and the idea of
playing Rook d8 at some point Bishop
back to B7 and somehow going C5
which of course is very logical to open
the diagonal of this bishop because both
sides have light squared Bishop but this
bishop on F6
is just on this diagonal and if the
position opens up this bishop is just
going to become such a powerful piece
so this is an idea that Benjamin pointed
out Benjamin corduro that is talking
about Benjamin Bach and they will be
playing tomorrow and collateral will
have the black pieces as he said he
always does uh which is quite
unfortunate in if you find yourself in a
Muslim situation but as we say Benjamin
here is pressing with the black pieces
so so still a lot can happen in the
Stream
but no matter what tomorrow Battle of
the Benjamins so we're going to be
rooting for Benjamins tomorrow sure uh
what else do we have here so Christopher
you and Savion we looked at this okay so
this will be a trust one because after
G5
I think simple and the problem is Rook
H5 the problem with Rook 85 first I have
G4 just to win the pawn but also the
Rook on H5 I think maybe I don't even
have to win this Pawn immediately
because this Rook is so awkwardly placed
so this game I'm expecting uh to end in
a draw which um
a bit of a consolation for Savion who
started really well he had this really
nice win and then he lost two in a row
really tough games and I think he's
quite probably is happy here to make a
drop very comfortable draw here at the
better side of the dry here
and tomorrow we'll have the white pieces
and try to play for a win
and this other game oh wow tables have
churned no
this is not the game also have not look
at this game so now they're back versus
quesada Perez uh the position where we
started looking at this before the
broadcast it's funny this is the same
tactic that Archer charger played twice
so it's a very thematic tactic of this
round but there was an earlier position
where the position
[Music]
because this Knight is on C2 is just so
sad because after Rook on it won
I think he played Bishop City realizing
about this night because if you play
something like this this Knight is just
trapped this net literally does not have
a square to go to
wow yeah and you don't see something
like this very often and now if the
bishop moves back there's just not
enough space for white spaces because
they're all congregated on the queen
side and after The Rook goes on A8 uh
the queen is trapped
and I think this is what he realized and
he decides to give up his Exchange
which black doesn't even take because
why would you take the exchange for this
light script Bishop that's trapping all
of your opponent's pieces eventually
took and then went before and here he
played Rook 8 but this also looked very
strong because you're not able to take
because of check
and otherwise H2 is hanging but instead
he ran Rook A8
and now took on B4
Queen goes to B7 but uh it looks like
white maybe it's breathing a little
uh the problem with exchanging this now
this is also hanging and okay and this
Knight again doesn't have moves it's not
uh it's not getting a break in this game
maybe instead of um Bishop E7 Rook uh B1
was a try
just uh just
put our Rook on a better square and
Target the E4 Pawn but if I take are you
taking this one let's go this way I was
gonna take with my with my Pawn but
it still looks awfully unpleasant to
defend this position
probably you're just lost
so he too
he's also no he's not down on time so at
least
Rook D4 okay
I think unfortunately it was a white did
manage to get his pieces in the game
unfortunately it cost him all the pawns
but I wonder if
cage four oh very nice I wonder if we're
going to read some kind of a rook versus
knight three versus three kind of
position
right those those end games I think a
lot of people might expect them to be
like drawish because Rook vs Knight is
is a draw so if we have like three extra
pawns what difference does it make but
the thing is is those end games are
oftentimes just lost even if you have
um an extra an extra Pawn with the uh
with the side down the exchange
[Music]
the queen E2 Queen E1 would have been a
nice checkmate yeah this Rook went on an
adventure so now going on the B file
work on the second rank if I asked you
which route came from the King side and
which word came from the queen side
could you could you tell me I would
think this
is something like this okay so 23
attacking F2 I've I've just learned that
quesada actually has already won this
game and we will be getting an interview
an interview with him so that's uh
that's gonna be very nice okay
uh
play Felix blauberger and Jason Liang so
Jason Liang if he wins this game he
takes the
title and a lot of things have happened
since we last looked at this position
which was somewhere around here actually
we saw all of this
and uh no this is not what we're
considering so in this position we're
thinking
we're not considering this move Knight
C3 we were thinking about maybe a
passing move like King F7 but instead
Knight C3 is played
so a lot of exchanges happened and now
we see this Knight
is um this Knight is in kind of a funny
position because it should be two okay
so change of the structure and but
luckily for white the knight from E3
defends everything defends this forever
will defend G2 and because it's a light
Square Bishop it cannot be kicked out so
it can D4 Queen C1 King F7 and we have
Rich move 40 so I think there's going to
be a long thing but in the meantime we
do have the winner of group a uh he has
our quesada Perez who won this game with
the black pieces so thank you for
joining us and uh let's go through the
game so we saw the end a little bit but
let's start from the beginning so we
have seen this position almost every
round everyone seems to be playing this
for nights English yeah it was there was
a game was a good um the opening very
strange because
I decide uh play with a essays by we
fight with sacrifice upon
but I think I always want better but are
you expecting this queen bee to remove a
Queen Bee Tree is uh of course not is it
no is the the main of the opening but it
is important
for providing D5
um
I analyze
um this position uh
two years ago I think I I see and before
was a good idea but I don't know if
what Manus play
okay then that's how we know it's a
great idea yeah
I will be it
um okay A3 yes it that is a important
moment because if A4 a i play A5 no
um
a square before
and if D4 it wasn't interesting
Ed
take Tech and D5
like before
um
so there's no way to
wait yes I
I good for black
um yeah E3
um
I saw many times in this position
because
I need to decide
if sacrify pong or or play solid with
with E8 disease but I think B5 was a
good
and idea so you spend some time so did
you decide this over the board or this
is something you had prepared yeah I I
saw this position two years ago but I
don't remember all but I see
B5 is the idea
okay so you sacrifice upon he takes and
what is the idea behind sacrifice
I I have more control for the center
[Music]
um
tactically just lose so he has to go to
remove
this
that's a good move because I prevailing
and before
um
like if you score D5 before and then
so you start with C5 yes
this moment is uh
a Critic moment
um for white
because my plan is my idea is D5 which
this is an attack with King side
[Music]
um
yes I I saw the in the game
and before I I think this was for me it
was a good move
which this is
with a take
um
which we do take in between
yes yes but maybe I don't know if
but it's strange for
eign
and then you still win the pond yeah
yeah the position
is
trying for a foreign and if something
like H3 he probably just attack right
yeah the floor is very strong yeah this
is very unpleasant so what did you think
what uh you thought that D4 is the best
move here I don't know but for me in the
in the area I think he played before but
he played Knight C2 was
what D5 before Queen C7 it was a a good
move because my problem my idea Knight
E4
so if it takes 94 Nifty three and 95
I have three let me just Checkmate yeah
on the light squares that looks that
looks very dangerous
and so that's why he won Bishop B2 yes
if if H3
Queen E5
with idea 25 and Beverly Daniels yeah
because this King just has no Defenders
the problem at some point he has to try
something like a floor
yeah maybe thanks thanks
this looks so dangerous it feels like
something is going to be trying five
with
the yeah this is problem right because
this is hanging this is everything is
hanging yeah everything is very
unpleasant
so he went Bishop B2 to stop this yes
um
before I sing a picture of E4 but later
I understand more the position and 94 is
I think was a good move because virtual
default F3 if oh yeah if we show it
before F3 take
a
[Music]
this is
six yeah
oh you want to take with the pawn yeah
three through F2
if 97 for idea research H4 a virtual F1
and I don't know I don't understand that
position I think is very complicated for
ramp for both for for that I play 1994.
so you played Knight G4 with the idea
that he has to take
we could read this is again 95 okay our
first of FC's okay E5
[Music]
and don't take yeah yes
okay so instead Bishop took you took and
now the whole idea is that this Knight
is just trapped here yeah yeah so you
did in the game not like
like a snap just doesn't have any
squares to go to which is kind of funny
because it's not something we see very
often I have more Contour I am better
but will be tooth was uh
stay
see now
it's hard to find moves right because
what is your threat so you want to trap
the queen yeah
so he went Bishop B2 you played here
Bishop
c34 this is such a nice move because if
you take immediately then maybe
Rook but at least the Knight lives but
then you've Bishop C4 with this threads
forcing the Knight T1
than you too yeah and this but in that
position I think I well before I think
[Music]
we do
yeah I don't know if they something
before
yeah if I just looks better but
Bishop E3
or C3 but seriousness is for for black
but
it's not clear not clear
just try to win immediately
so instead you decided to play okay
and then you took on before
five all
right and then he managed to develop his
pieces but then he's just losing all his
funds unfortunately F3
A9 Knight E5
with both ideas no take and take it
foreign
so you just took so defending this guy
so at which this is here did you already
feel like you're winning like it's over
or still yeah this position is winning
for black none okay
it says
[Music]
with a TV
is winning for black yeah it was so
funny Europe went all the like to age
four age six six sometimes like all
around the port and then yeah your peace
domination is very strong here and
eventually yeah you just took everything
and the same tactic let's say in another
game with similar tactic with the idea
being you pick up this rook and you just
open exchange and the problem with with
King yes
congratulations on your game
hey Christopher
Okay so we've seen some of these games
he's very well prepared player so what
do you expect you will Face Tomorrow uh
where
um I play with Christopher
and in in Continental okay last round
two really yeah and we play with a draw
um
yes but
I think this I feel good in this moments
I I lost to to round but I happy with my
my chest
um
this tournament is very hard
I'll play a very strong but
tomorrow play a nice game
it's a nice way to finish is this your
last tournament in the US or do you have
any other tournaments no no yes are you
studying in Western yeah oh okay yeah
play many tournaments this year here in
the United States yes well good luck
tomorrow thank you so we're looking
forward to an exciting game you have a
very exciting opponent and hopefully we
can see you back here again okay so that
was yesterday Perez after his win with
the black pieces who's playing Crystal
for you tomorrow and that game uh is
still going somehow black managed to
hang on to this pond so let's see how
that happened after G5 takes takes Rook
G7 attacking this pawn and he decided
not to take this pawn and I think he's
what is he afraid of he is afraid of
checks
probably doesn't gonna go up but I think
this looks
um quite equal so I'm a bit surprised he
decided not to take
and then the Rook went here and King E2
and G4
um this is a bit
this is a bit mysterious to me because
why can't I just take this Pawn what is
going on
am I missing something very obvious
what is um what is Black's threat is it
something with E5 maybe and then E4 and
going after this Pawn that he was afraid
of
our uh that has to be it right because
otherwise might not take the Free Pawn
yeah but it's it's a little hard to
believe right like I play Rook G6 check
and then Rick
um
I guess
encouraged me if it's I don't think king
of C3 so the point is like let's say you
play something like this right and I
check you and I go here and now right I
have to connect it past font so this is
very very bad yeah I think I have to
start with kin C3 and then you play E4
also
so you want to go here and then yeah A4
with the threat of rookie two but now
now maybe we can activate yeah using the
Philadelphia principle so
see a check
I go King D6 and the point is if you
check uh sorry if you defend then I
still win the pawn yeah for sure so I
would like to play Rook d8
I go here
uh yeah all all the same I ideas from
the this is awesome you know it was very
funny because it's two horses too and
somehow are very dangerous but
can I play King D4 here because if you
play the same sequence then you hang the
D5 Pawn at the end
so like King C3 Rook D3 or you sure can
C5
the d-pawn is technically hanging
but I still think this end game is
dangerous so yeah straight
for I take probably like eh or yeah Rook
G6 also
it's very bad yeah well
the line I wouldn't I want to point out
just to show
so check so I uh here so you cannot take
because after I take this will be a draw
so instead I will move my Rook
um maybe even here
actually where do I want to move my Rook
to have some fighting chances
but yeah when I just want to keep your
cut off
and now my claim is your king is really
cut off and if you stay on the fifth
rank I'll just push my pawn and actually
I think yeah you can't even stop you
might be losing already because how do
you stop this
and if you go back then so I cannot push
my palm because now I cannot defend it
and now I just go King E5 and I'm
playing with two pieces and you're
playing
with one book maybe this is
still tough to win because if I play
Rook E1 here and then you go okay
somewhere and I play G5
um
and then G6 it's like
almost in time
I think it it means to be like pretty
precise like G6
so if I go here you booked you on
well
no Pokemon can give two yeah I was
thinking more along the lines of G7 but
I think you're in time actually I think
you do win G7 I think I think I pick up
yeah I just saw and I just promote my
Pawn right well Rook C1 here is like a
trick but
huh
yeah yeah okay so maybe here
um I was wondering if I have time to
take it but I don't think I need to do
that
um
no I think King F3 is already winning
here
yeah I I agree
so wow this position actually has a lot
of danger 2v2 so let's
let's fight King D3
but this position looks awfully
dangerous to me as well I think that
this is not not the easiest 3v2 to hold
I think in general and we're component
endings you'd prefer to have the central
pawns and uh black black has the center
ponds here that can cause white some
Danger
so what is uh so what is the difference
here so he went King
Ri so let's say he goes King
so let's say I go King C3 here what uh
so my idea is if you check then I go
back
which is not something I want at least
you don't have this because I take this
right
but you do have King F5 but then how do
you make progress do you maybe want to
go D4 and take on G3 and then you have a
very annoying pass Pawn
or but now you can check me right
because I don't have this move if you go
here
yeah so and if I go here now you have
Rook F4
yeah this actually looks kind of safe
for white
so then that means this is not something
I want to do
so if you go King C3
what is Black's plan
so again like this checks
and worse yeah we don't want to love
this
King maybe King D6 and E5 just play slow
because if I can get my cane back around
to E4 with the pawn on E5 I think you
are actually in some danger because I
think Rook F4 is the
um
the base of your defense
and if you go so now if I get this one
I'll be quite happy if I get this one
else I'll also be quite happy and the
idea is also with checks I might be able
to cut off your king
still feels like there should be some
defensive resources so it's
Christopher's move and he is after K4
he's thinking of what to do so there's
several waiting moves I think King City
is one it's also possible to wait with
this move although perhaps this move
just immediately runs into this
with a Tempo with the idea of E4
yeah so let's say I attack
now we have to oh this is just Perpetual
it's a funny Perpetual because you can
never go to D7 because uh or E7 because
D5 is hanging you can never go to D7
because E5 is hanging so you have to be
careful when you time this E5 push Maybe
so let's not do it so I can yeah but we
saw this check doesn't really help us
so what can we do here maybe we can be
clever some kind of a triangulation here
yeah maybe King E7 first and then when
you give check I'll go to D6
I don't know if you want to give check
or we could just go to D6 maybe yeah and
then just try to play E5
mm-hmm
yeah again I'm wondering if let's say
okay let's say you wait this way
you want to go D4 Rook a three Rook G3
yeah I wanna because this is a concrete
line so I wanna
I think not there I think maybe white
would go to E4 though with the point
that once you take on G6 I have D5 yeah
but I think even this position if I
could somehow get it I think this should
be a draw
let's say I go here you go here
is this a draw
it doesn't feel like a draw anymore I
don't I don't like having the Canon G2
because it's cut off from the
Pawn on D4
so I cannot take on G4 because that's a
losing King and pun in game so what do I
do yeah the reason why it's losing is
you can immediately get to the key
squares so the key squares here would be
D4 E4 and F4 and black just gets there
King D4 and you win
and E5 ah so this is actually a really
well time D5 because if checked and
immediately here and no Perpetual I
think maybe in this similar position how
did we do it that our King was going
maybe we went King E6 maybe yeah that
was wrong yeah that was maybe imprecise
so E5 with the thread of E4 so this is
the second time I'm seeing some play
some kind of a rook end game
with some funny tricks we saw that
really amazing looking game against uh I
think it was against Daniel yeah that's
right Daniel Darr with that really
amazing save that uh nobody nobody saw
yeah but it's so fresh in my mind
because it was just such a fascinating
game and again we see him squeezing some
kind of an end game
Christopher here played a move
so we're expecting
sorry about that cooking goes to E7
and um maybe he goes back so E4 so let's
try this
I'm just going down the most forced move
first variation rather and
yeah yeah
it's a question so yeah yeah this should
this should just be a drop because once
you take on G3 I take on e4
and yeah if you go here actually just
completely in the game yes
Rook F3 I'll hold that too yeah rookette
three King G4 only move but you know
both Rooks are handing to both kins and
Kane versus Kane is what will be
achieved
and so this is a fascinating end game
but uh still I think some pressure for
um
because uh for right because if you go
here maybe I don't have to go for it can
I try I can give seven seven do you have
Rook d8 with the idea if you go here now
I can rookie eight
yeah maybe we can give a check first
like
um from here oh G4 is just hanging
yeah
I mean after King F7 Rook d8 we get uh
we give check maybe and then here King
E6 and then when you give your Perpetual
with rookie 8d8 I can go to F5 and and
now maybe this is this is unpleasant
because you no longer have the move Rook
F4
okay four with with black yeah oh yeah
okay that's clever oh yeah this is
actually so here I probably have to go
Rook G8
but now you have check and now you go
off
I mean I don't want to get caught off
okay this just yeah yeah just one in so
I have to go this way and now before
and I think this is correct
for
yourself before is anything lots of
tricks for both sides
yeah but this is uh this is starting to
look quite unpleasant for white so let's
say I go here here again and then D4
even
just oh but maybe you give me a check
because this would be I think just
losing for white the pawn should be too
sh oh I said maybe I spoke too soon it's
cut yeah
never never mind broken games are so
tricky yeah D4 is a bad move
okay
so king7 and we're expecting Rook G8 but
we will let uh so Christopher again is
up on time Christopher is always up on
time it's amazing so we will let
Christopher figure out his defense here
let's take a look at the game between
Abby and Benjamin because this is very
important for our standings and I see a
lot of exchanges have happened and black
is up a pawn but opposite color Bishops
but I feel like every day the resistance
right some kind of an imbalance there's
uh some position with Heavies where King
is getting checked maybe that was a
color Fisher with Rooks on the position
so it's like a very thematic tournament
and Rook end games right so it's this
recurring teams that we have here but I
think white is not unhappy because once
this bishop goes to D3 it's such a nice
piece you can really kick it out and
then also you're taking care of Entry
squares and I think um yeah because it's
kind of a comfortable position already
compared to what white had before or
this is I think a dream because White
had a position where he had a worse
structure and had to play against the
bishop pair so somehow white gave up a
pawn in exchange for trading off one of
the Bishops and making it opposite color
Bishops which makes drawing chances
higher so he took this
traded this for this yeah so let's see
how that happens so Queen went to B2 and
this is not possible because Knight D5
that's cool that is a very funny way of
Defending upon even it's actually even
worse than that right because Bishop D4
Knight D5 you take on B2 Knight Knight
b4's a fork on your A6 Bishop in the C6
Pawn so why might even be playing for
the advantage there yeah this is quite
unpleasant so instead he played
not this he played Bishop C8 attacking
this Pawn twin went back so he took okay
so actually black force is straight
and queen F4 defending the pawn
so King went back to G8 so maybe one and
okay nice
maybe this was just a mistimed um
simplification by by Bach maybe bishop
F5 was not totally necessary to play for
to play for an advantage
not that I know what the black should do
but
um I I like the two Bishops I would I'd
probably just play slow here like even a
move like Bishop D7 or and then just let
white find moves uh the problem for
white is their main plane is associated
with G4 G5 but for them to get in G4 G5
so first if you go G4 let's say Bishop
D7 this Pawn hangs so you have to
somehow play something like
King H3 or something and okay here I'm
hanging the D4 Pawn but um
my point is even if you get in G4 it's
very difficult to get in G5 because you
need to move the rook and once you move
the Rook this Pawn hangs so in this
position why was this not possible is
there some
hold on
I'm holding on the night has to jump
right so not here this is a free piece
so where is the Knight jumping to
eat eat soup maybe ah and if here you
have F6
yeah and then you kind of regret having
picking on a fade because something like
this and yeah now practically it becomes
very difficult to play Black
yeah this one would be very scary
people f8 but then H5 is like
let's say King G8 you defend but then I
come
back and then H5 is coming all of a
sudden they're starting to look a bit
scary and
I think white is quite happy with the
change of the flow of the game
yeah certainly
so in the final position a4a5 so this
bishop wants to go to C5 but I expect
this bishop to go to D3
and hopefully this Rook is not getting
trapped it's not because I have the C7
Square
um so white is quite happy with the
trade of the Rooks and
and this
um very likely to end in a draw
so let us jump to Group B our key
matchup of the day so since you left for
me to do this interview I don't know if
you saw all of this what happened in
this game
in this position that Knight C3 was
played
and all of these exchanges happened
Queen went to B2 and I went to D2 and
then exchange on F3 so black structure
is actually quite ugly
but there's some issues long-term issues
with this King
93 luckily covers everything yeah 94. I
don't know uh if you agree with this
claim but I think that uh if if black
managed to trade Queen somehow then why
would just be losing because I think
that the bishop is better than the
Knight and the the protected pass Pawn
is really strong
uh I who would disagree with that claim
because I think if I put a king on C3
so if I somehow
let's see
so Quincy one okay let's try to take
this queens of the board I think I
actually have a fortress here because I
don't think you're in time to push
I think if you push this Pawn I'm
actually going to
win this one
Bishop B1 here oh then you go and take
my B6 Pawn or C3 Pawn Knight D5 yeah
okay
so F5 is hanging and the only reason I
couldn't take a 5 because the spawn
would Queen but now I might be
threatening to take in five and if you
don't push this Pawn for example if you
put a bishop on E6
at the very least I will do this
not there let's say here here and I I
took away all your entry squares
and I think just the fact that my knight
only 3 is not letting your king and I
just have a fortress and um and if you
go here I can put a king on C4 and in
this position I can just
um the thing is this is kind of a mutual
succubunk right because if you move your
Bishop I take on F5 and if you move your
Bishop I take the king but let's say
let's let's do this let's pass the move
to White and see if I may be in trouble
with white
I don't think I am because if I move my
knight and you check me I can go to
can I even go here
actually I might even be able to go here
because oh this is funny there's still
no entry squares still there
oh this reminds me of some study where
this was like the final position was it
uh
famous blood work versus Jason Liang
yeah I don't I don't think they were
featured
this is funny of course everything with
it was um not with a lot of neurons
we're just making very forcing moves oh
we are breaching and
that's that's that's interesting so my
first yeah my first impression was uh
was totally wrong I guess the entry
squares or it just can be well guarded
by white and um
uh it's pretty difficult to make use of
your past Palm with black but we've got
kind of uh what we're looking at now
white has a better version of it ah but
this is
wait a minute sorry black has the better
version of it but what is going on here
at first I was thinking night in the
pond keeping your king out but then I
realized it move your Bishop you go here
and then your king comes in so this is a
bit different because the king is
already only seven
and we've stopped the other king from
coming in Bishop C4 is very nice we've
essentially traded taking the a pawn for
stopping white skin from getting in the
game and black has assessed that it's
more dangerous to put his Bishop on C4
and stop Kane F1 than it was to capture
White's a pawn
so King D6 played so what is White's
idea because if white doesn't do
anything actually I cannot even not do
anything because I don't have moves so
maybe King H2 and G4 at some point so
let's say do you still got G4 I mean not
anymore I wanted to go G4 when he had to
take with the pawn and I could get a
past F Pawn so let's say here you're
afraid of this right
yeah oh so maybe then
we have to start with G4
thank you good here
um so let's say C4
my idea is
um
to just bring in my cake this looks very
dangerous for white
yeah for sure so how do I stop here can
I go 94
can I go eight no it's four looks very
bad it's because I'm just giving the
world so I think already here A4 maybe I
think it only move United Force I cannot
because if you go King C7
which may be oh you don't even do
because you're gonna play C3 and snip B6
but I have to make a move
oh yeah this is the problem in first you
have to make a move but what do I play
here if I so I cannot I can if I keep
this bishop here
I think here you'll have
to play actually here I'm just gonna
keep my knight here and just wait for
you to go to D5 and
I like what's playing for a win probably
even with like
for a bishop is too many pawns okay so
let me not do this I've been
I mean I have to
okay
Knight A4 back
I keep thinking I have to take on C4 but
then I realized that because I can go B6
and then B7 and then herb well if you go
here then I'll take on G4
think and then I I have F5 F6 F7
so this is enough
forcing you to take and I take on F3
okay so let's let's go back to looking
to six
no
the position we're looking at G4
which we found you for because we're
afraid of Bishop B4
although maybe I'm sorry Bishop B6 maybe
bishop E6 runs into Knight A4
immediately but okay I I kind of like
this configuration because
uh now we have a pawn to play against
and then we're thinking C4 again
thinking very directly
and Knight a4s suggested by Julian
so I will promote this so Knight A4 with
the idea being that black has to make a
move so let's say I go here can you take
already I think I think so and then once
you take on B5 I I think I I take on C4
with am I okay to take on C4 with the
Knight because I think you have to
because otherwise is wrong
yeah and then I I try to do the same
thing where I distract your Bishop with
F5 F6 F7 but of course I have the a pawn
also so that your cane has to
to guard both sides but then
so
um
because I'm blocking the players now
yeah so King G5 is smart yeah and then
A4 A5 so on
what do you mean by so long if you go if
I make a bishop move
uh F6 when I go here again G6
yeah I don't think you can stop both my
pawns now
okay so let me try not to lose let me go
here
um
till
well King G4 is a funny move but
probably right okay thank you
okay let's say F6 right then I go
and four and then if I'm just waiting
six yeah six is coming okay but let's
see why is this so if I do this yeah
whenever you take now F7
and then if I wait you just push this
pawn and now I actually I am
what was it
so G4 seems to be a critical move in
this position
so what other moves come to mind if not
G4 because something like this
yeah this looks even better straight
unfortunately the Knight here is
extremely dominated I'm actually
wondering if the Knight is trapped
yeah I was wondering the same thing King
C6 there's Knight C8 and King C7 there's
Knight D5 so
it's it's maybe not so easy but but this
should be enough here right because in
all these positions
um
yeah white its king is on
23.
yeah and now I just put a king here
it's not the same when you have to fight
against one Pawn Yeah
yeah oh no the Mobile's not played I
just saw the red box and I thought oh
mother's plate okay so in this position
all right I'm lost
oh okay the mothballs played
so King H2 was played and Bishop D3
we're looking at Bishop E6 but instead
Bishop E3 so now I think G4 really comes
to mind right because you don't really
have any other moves can I wait
I can't right because Bishop theater
comes with a threat so I have to make a
threat myself
so G4 is kind of a process of Animation
actually reaching for something he's
reaching for G4 I think yeah but then he
looks at his clock reaches back and he's
thinking but I think of course he
understands that uh this Pawn is
Sephora King comes in this King kind of
funny how this King got boxed in
so we expect him to play G4 which I
think he did if I'm seeing it correctly
yeah before played
so we expect all these moves it doesn't
really make sense for
black not to take it if C4 I think
wait
you're not even in this yeah no you
cannot even get punk
um okay your king is still in the square
right but not not in the square of both
pawns so if you go like King E6 which
you must otherwise like Queen then a
four a five I think comes in
yeah I think that's it this would be
silly so of course black token F takes
G4 and H takes G4 and actually it's
interesting he took F Pawn because if
you take with this Pawn I might even
think about going H4 and then white is
playing for for the win so King G3 H5
King H4 and at least we have I have a
pass Pawn right so that means you have
to dedicate at least one piece stop to
stop it because uh otherwise
upon my run so H takes C4 H takes C4 and
King G3 will come all of this are very
four Sig moves very logical moves we
expect Bishop F5
I guess C4 is a move to consider and
King C5 but
is this anything can we go F5 King D4
are we afraid of this or this is
something we already saw yeah F6
the Knight D1 I guess and then you want
to put your horse here
right I was thinking yeah Knight E3 was
strong because if you go C2 then I take
it in F7
but you don't have to play C2 right away
and then you take on
I was thinking A4 after King D3
I'm thinking sorry what oh yeah
F4 only only slight cheating
six and I think the bishop is
funny enough if we transport the bishop
to D5 the same problem exists because
once I push the pawn you take I push the
other Pawn so it doesn't work out
yeah I'm curious how does black hold
after Knight to D1 because I saw that
bar drop but
it seems so C3 Knight E3 and then
what to do with it's black
um
so
later is not a move King the three was
losing or maybe you go keaney five and
just take my f Pawn
can I try your idea
yeah
uh maybe this time I can get my cane
back in time to defend against that pawn
so something like oh okay if you're just
waiting this actually might be dangerous
right because King D6 yeah
and somehow my Bishop holds the pawn
it's amazing card this is zeros because
my block has a million pounds right
so bizarre
I'd rather play Black in that final
position for sure so Jason is thinking
so must mean he's considering C4 because
otherwise Bishop F5 is automatic right
you don't actually have that many moves
that make sense you either protect the
pilot Bishop F5 or you go
um
C4 so here we're considering uh we're
considering negative four here or King
H4
so
because King G5 G3 right
think about five
in night A4 I I kind of like because I
think I'm forcing you to play King C7
and what was
yeah
I think just take a 93 and we're just in
time not to lose um
so something like this right
[Music]
eventually
you give up this pawn and I think Felix
is more than happy with the drawing this
position he is under a lot of pressure
and he has been regardless of what the
bar says it does feel like he was under
pressure in this game because
um
uh just the Practical aspect of it is
opponent's pieces seems to be doing
really well at some point and then the
structural changes it's really well
played by Jason I think entering this
end game where now white has to find
this idea and in some lines we're seeing
how he has to find this idea to give up
his Knight and force a drum
so after Bishop F5 uh it's so King age
four
C4 probably still has to go for this and
looks like a transposition so night City
now we just repeat
the problem is we can never play for
anything more with King G5 because as we
saw King G5 runs into G3 and this Pawn
is Unstoppable so this is very
unfortunate
and otherwise
I didn't mean to go that far back
otherwise this idea of Knight F4 is the
key idea
attacking this pawn and if we get to
take both pawns we're quite happy
because at some point this bishop has to
get distracted to stop RP pawn and then
we take the rest of the pawns or and if
black goes to C7 we go back to C3 and
then we're just repeating
so this seems to be like a nice resource
Bishop F5 plate and now white to move
white is away from the board but yeah
probably gonna play Knight A4 I I would
guess you think he will play it
immediately or he's going to spend some
time he must have thought about Bishop
F5 right you know before this is not
considered Bishop F5 so I think maybe
either King H4 or Knight A4 probably
leaving the King on G3 yeah I don't
think it really makes a difference
whether the Kings on H4 or G3 because we
always just hold everything from either
one of those squares so I don't I
personally I would play Knight A4 first
but I don't think it matters too much
and let's go back to our group a and
let's see
if there's been any progress in this
game we left off here
there's been some move play so the Rooks
came off the board
let's see how that happened no I've done
too far again
so on Rook C8 that's how we're
considering uh Bishop E2
so the king comes in Pawn to H5 and
starts putting his pants on light
squares
now the king is coming in uh so his idea
here is going to be
to play King not there you can get two
and whenever black plays King C5 King C5
to be met with
Bishop to B7 so you're not able to do
this H5 is quite annoying against the
structure because if I ever attack F7
you have to go F6 which means the pawn
structure becomes fixed so for example
if
I can make a few moves let's say we go
back
so let's say if something like this
happens right
this is a very easy Fortress for me to
hold already because I'm always
attacking this pawn and I can always
stay on this diagonal actually your king
cannot even move away because the spawn
is hanging so and if you ever do
something like this then yeah there's
just my king here and there's just no
more winning or losing this game with
either color
so this would be quite comfortable draw
for
for Mishra if this happens but I I think
already here this looks quite
comfortable maybe black can try for a
bit I think you can achieve more or less
that position by force
um if black tries King C5 we can go to
D7 right and then we go to
um
I meant D7 with the with the bishop
because if you go to oh no actually
maybe now you can go to B4 not my
mistake no this is this is not what you
want oh this is this is this is danger
zone so how I thought that I would still
be attacking yep Bishop B7 is a better
way just always attacking the d-pawn
and then
this is impossible and
it's actually kind of
opt this is very comfortable position we
should now just goes to D5 and
we don't worry about our pawns pink on
the dark squares because it's not even
possible to attack them so there is no
good configuration for black to do this
maybe he needs to go from E5 and then we
attack this and then he goes this way
and then tries to go through D4 but here
we can just
um if you go this way I can just wait
because your pieces are in the way of
each other so you cannot really
do anything so you can never go here I
will take and if you ever go to E4 then
you're pinned so yeah maybe the only way
black can try to win is to play a move
like G6 and then hope that white trades
on G6 and create a past Pawn but after
G6 I think white will just play the move
G4
and uh the structure will remain the
same
what I do is to try to
treat maybe a bit dangerous actually
yeah that's a possibility so to try to
play for a win change the pawn structure
and G6 was played
so he's listening to you not not good
not good news
so Netflix maybe there are some targets
here but hard to imagine so let's say if
the king gets passive if we the problem
is I'm always attacking you I'm always
attacking your puns but if we get some
kind of Bishop C5 like something like
this and then all of a sudden
like something
okay but uh White has to be very
Cooperative to get this yeah this looks
dangerous for weight at this
point so after the g64 is played
and
but now he's not going to let any of
this happen he's just I think he will
just leave his King here
and keep buying this pawn and
whenever you do something like this I'll
just wait with the bishop and whenever
you go here I'll go here
and if you put your Pawn on F5 I will
what will I do
maybe we can go this way
maybe this position can get annoying so
for example if I wait you go here
my idea was to do this
but now maybe I can actually lose this
Pawn
yeah maybe
um
we can play Bishop E2 instead of Bishop
D3
and just whenever you play King G5 move
Arcane away like King G3 but
obviously I'm not happy
but maybe this is
still ah but now you go back so maybe
still a fortress of some sort
and let's go back to this Christopher
game which is Savion
of oh he got the g-pawn how did that
happen wow so seven seven is really good
winning chances here so avoid Rook end
games again
we did not consider uh defense on the
fifth rank
or repeating Grandmasters left to repeat
and this is how you got the pawn
King E7 and through Rook G6 but uh why
not check again I think you just end up
on C5 so like King D6 Rook H6 King C5
and then if you attack me again then E4
will come and I will just take your G
Pawn
unfortunate
so instead he played group G6 Rook G3
King E2 and Rook G2 Ah that's clever
because now he has King F1
and if here then you have this move
so how do I hang on to my Palms
you know Rook Rook F3 keaney 2. it's
very fortunate that um the g-pawn is
attacked and Rook G3 are kind of you're
kind of repeating the position ah so
this is
so Rook G2 King F1 but can we still
fight two versus I mean two versus one
and your king is cut off
so we can still try it right
so you just want to go with and play
Kenny six again
uh yeah that's that's a better path
because I was going to point out that if
you play um
uh something like Keen F6 and I go Rook
to B4 I believe after knife five E4
should be one of these uh drawn
positions
the philador with two extra pawns I
think is still a draw
why is this a drum
um
so I think we still wait on the third so
Rook B3 then I play
then King E1
and then uh E3 it's still Rook or Rook
B8
so Rook f8 King E3 Rook F3 is my my big
trick
yeah I see
okay so in the game the king went to E1
why
what's wrong with King ah sir King F7 no
here okay enough six
two eight
um
Rook cheese Rook G3 here maybe and if
you go king of two Rook F3 akiny2 king
of five
oh that's really nice oh these guys are
so good I want to be good
yeah me too
so unbeatable for sure how did we do
this
so after it's funny right because once
something is played then you're like oh
this must be the reason and then you
figure it out
so we said if King F1 then King F7
so if here
then Rook D2 and uh yeah just Rook D3
and E4 I think this Construction
might win
wait I wanted to try something can I
play here
oh man that's fancy but fancy is how we
don't win you always play the tactics
fancy is a danger zone when you have a
winning position you start going to
fancy this is how you make
blunders okay
I think this actually
a big threat okay
so
let's see how we did this I want to go
through this again so we said King F1 we
went King F7 Rook G5 so taking only five
is a very simple win
yeah we get we're on a key square and
Kane on the sixth always wins even if
the Kane were back on E1 and the Kane is
nowhere near uh being able to stop the
pawn on D5
and otherwise if you got
to go King F5 and if I so we said to
check here devastating and if I wait
with Rook G7 but now your Rook is free
and you we don't play King E4 anymore we
just play with two extra pawns which
should be enough to win the game
yeah hurricane games down two pawns
usually
usually are lost
but with some exceptions this should be
enough right
um why why not just work or
okay yeah yesterday I go back I was
thinking Rook H2 and then if you go to
G3 Rook E2 yeah this should be enough
because
to win the game so this is just game
over here a really nice play by Savion
finding all the resources
so maybe Christopher is going to regret
not taking that pawn so kinky one he is
thinking so what is he thinking here is
it is his skin just cut off on the sixth
rank is this the issue if I go King F7
do you just
kind of chill here
it's hard to believe right because I
just push and then next maybe you try
Rook D6 instead of her k6
like King F7 Rick D6 with white trying
to hold
oh yeah
that's oh that's actually maybe why he
went to E1 right because Rick D6 he
could in previous positions you could go
to D2 but the Canon E1 actually guards
the D2 Square
and if I go here now you can go to
cook
it's so weird these these players like
how much uh Nuance they have to see in
these these end games they had to see
this Kane F1 k9f7 thing and
here they have to see like Rook D6 uh
there's no more Rook D2 after kinia one
and maybe I I don't even know if the
position is a win or a draw and it just
keeps going back and forth in my head so
if I go here so King F2 so if you go
here
here does T4 win the game
should where's like we'll soon
so I have an idea here so takes takes
can you have to write
and now I'm gonna play here
yeah always with the and the problem for
you is your king gets in the way
yeah there's some very famous study with
this idea but oh no
oh no wait but this has does it have to
be
wait so Kenny for
maybe after your work takes chief wait
wait wait so maybe I need to go here
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is what this was the stud there's a
study where they play like Rook G4 then
Rook D and then you have to play like D1
Rook instead because Rook D4 is still
made for some reason I don't quite
remember the position yeah and they're
like the king is on the corner though
they're getting mated
[Music]
the king is in the way
but in the game something completely
different was played G3 was played
no sorry
was
bikini one is the last move I believe so
here we're considering
or it's a different candy one somehow no
no this was and then
instead of King F7 he played G3
so G3 here
and now he's going to put a Pawn on e4
right because nothing else makes unless
there's king of no King F7 I can go to
G4
there's nothing special about this so he
will put a pawn only four
and now he has this nice configuration
and the question is
how do you make progress yeah but what
does white do
I think this is
um
oh so if you move your Rook off the six
that my king comes in if you move your
Rook off the G file then I play G2 but
I'm not sure G2 wins
because but maybe I can go to King F7
not threatening G2
and if you check me then I just stay
I mean this this looks
like my king is going in
okay you cannot do this because
um P2 is actually winning here
yeah
okay this is
okay F6
wait Rook D1 wait um sorry why not King
G4
it's getting difficult question no I
mean this is just
yeah no I thought there's Rook d8 but
okay this must be kicking G3 right
it's Rook F1 winning now we'll get fun
looks making like a rook of one I'll say
yeah a rookie three
yeah
There's Something Magic position
so
so G file
and what do I do
so King D6 I thought was the big idea
but then it's hard to hit I wait and
time you come here come here start
checking you
so how do we win so I just keep checking
so I just check it forever yeah and then
I come back
yeah that's a that's a good question
play it and
let's say Rook G5
the king is sex
can I
what can I do
how do I win this
can I somehow
give up this
um
teapot
let's say you go here and I go here or
you go here
um
you can see for
eign
or am I no but this must be
right
G8
I didn't see this one I think it's just
filters now
you love your photos I yeah I try to
play philador in every position
I've never won a game in my life all my
rating points come from performing
philators
all right so my table base tells me this
is drawn so that's helpful
okay so I should not be doing this
so how do we win this
and this is a position we have on the
board Rook G5 plate attacking this Pawn
I presume King D6 and let's say we go
back
um
triangulate somehow
yeah I was I was wondering how dangerous
the position would be if I like King E5
Rook G5 and then Kenny E6 and now it's
white to play
here no maybe King F5
it's all the same
I feel it there uh what do we do what do
we do
not see it
Rook Jade played this is a fascinating
end game it's like up to pawns but this
configuration is just so funny one can
give six tempting came with Rook f8
this is good Temptation so take take
yeah and you lose
maybe if it was
no if it was about to play wait if it
was blocked I would like to play Black
still wins yeah King H4 King F3 King H3
no but that will go here
no but then you triangulate with King G5
very nice yeah
okay now we're playing
so
so he's not going to do this he will go
King Chief Rook G4
and now what is Sam's plan here
Rook G4 was played yeah
[Music]
to something but it's not working by the
way very nice defense by by Christopher
I mean we we give a lot of credit to
savian for playing these Rook end games
so tricky and putting a lot of pressure
on his opponent but Christopher had to
play really well not to just lose like
so many times before he got here
yeah and uh actually on the clock we see
32 minutes to one minute so Sam has only
one minute to figure out this end game
and Christopher's moves are very easy
it's just waiting on the G file and of
course some can also make up a lot of
moves but just shuffling around can make
up a lot of time but the question is if
he's going to find a winning plan
and in the meantime let's take a peek at
other games okay King E5 Rook G5 play
let's take a peek at The crucial game in
group b between
Felix and Jason so let me promote and
this is the position that we have so
let's go back oh it looks like we are
reaching a repetition here
so all of this was played let me promote
this variation
so this was played Knight A4 he went
back and so far they're repeating Knight
C3 so how many times is it already
so if he goes King D6 this will be
threefold so let me see so this is one
time
so Jason can claim on this move is what
I've Been Told
uh oh yeah Jason can claim but I think
Jason is the one trying and if he goes
so this is the position if he goes King
D6 which he didn't
so black is trying to play for a win
here so if we go Knight A4 is this
dangerous can you go here
no but this uh I feel like I'm having a
Deja wolf but here I might even go this
way right or no yeah
probably up a few tempos on the previous
lines
or is this the same like idea Knight C3
Knight D1
um well King so now you have to go away
I mean instead of oh instead of B6
Knight C3 and then King D4 and I do
Knight D1
and if you play C3 I'll take it and go
B7 and F5 and so on
it's possible we'll have a three-fold
later on but uh he's keeping the game
going because he he realizes because if
he draws this then
um there's a full point behind going
into the last round and then puts him in
a Muslim situation and it requires Felix
to lose which is always tough relying on
other people to
uh
to make your results happen for you
and more events you need than the less
the likelihood lowers right because you
have to have so many events happen at
the same time which has happened to me
before when I was leading going into a
half round and I lost and my closest
competitor won but you know this is um
that's something he wants to do because
this is his chance he's playing the
leader and he can Shuffle around and try
to take him down so Knight A4 is a move
is are there any other moves his King
age for a move
so Knight A4 what was our idea after C4
we go back King D6 and we go back
and King D5
yeah take and take on C4 and try to make
a draw like that is what I was gonna do
maybe the computer finds some way to win
but I was I was very happy to just make
a draw here oh this was our idea right
here
let's say here yeah at some point I'll
go F5 F6 F7 and trade my
well here here will win
yeah
if you go after my F2 Pawn I'll probably
just defend and then claim your Bishop's
overworked yeah so
this is did we look at this is this also
a move
so what if I just keep shuffling here
somewhere okay I moved the pump so I
shouldn't be afraid of going to have
five ah now you check
and once again
C40 E3 is the construction
of here
oh that's unfortunate yeah
I uh I totally saw that and uh
definitely play 93 not based off luck
so if I go back what do we do okay A4
right
yeah yeah I think I can make a draw
um like I can wait yeah canage four Keys
the king cannot move from the square so
it's funny because neither King can move
from the square he went F5
oh wow I would not have
done that personally because I I want
this Pawn later so I can take the F3
Pawn but
but I guess he's calculated something
concrete so
three but I can simply go back so it's
possible that this might cost him
um the game right because in a lot of
lines we needed this F Pawn to make a
draw
and um
so there was the idea is to go here
and if you go to piece seven now your
favorite Construction
but uh is this ah and now my king can
actually activate because
um some G3 has been guarded
in a way
yeah I was gonna ask ask this question
but it is awfully risky to do this well
it's a king and pawn end game right so
we can calculate until the end
actually
one time there's this uh rule if you can
make a box at the end of the board with
two pawns and they Queen even without
help with the King
and uh so if you have two past pawns and
you can draw a box to the end with with
both of the pawns so like yeah like
pawns on B5 and it's an F5 yeah like
that then the pawns can Queen by
themselves
and if they
sorry I didn't know this rule oh really
no okay yeah
uh yeah this is
I mean connected past plans are strong
for this kind of system past funds
they're stronger so 95 plate
and what if what if we try so King B7 83
but okay uh we're under no obligation to
take we can go after this Pawn
so King F3 Bishop B5 are we happy here
is white we must be right so maybe 95 to
cut off the king or King E4 there's a
lot of moves here it's hard to pick
child got a form
already feels like we're in the draw
territory right
yeah it does it does feel like we've
simplified the position a bit
so maybe just good calculation by by
Felix
um
[Music]
maybe Kenny five
I don't think yeah me you just go B6
here
and like these six
well actually am I in time to do this oh
yes yeah you have the the trick the
knife
for once the night
[Music]
tonight we're getting some moves in he
played King B7 and here we're saying 93
which has been played
so this was the whole idea and it's
Jason to move and
he will either go to
D3 or D7 I think right because
did we look at Bishop t37 now we only
looked at Bishop B6 so why not just
attack immediately
um did we'll look at this we saw a
version of this
how did we get here no we went on the
3-6
getting lost in my arrows again so why
not here
so you take with the King probably right
yeah because your knight is well placed
and actually you get a very active King
it's push the pawn
and
getting very close to draws here
excuse me P5
hard to believe
hard to believe so in group a Mishra and
Bach have drawn their game which means
that uh Bach preserves his uh
uh his tie for first place but does not
does not move into Soul lead
and um I guess savian is still trying to
beat
uh you
but yeah our most important game is
still going to be um
still going to be this block Burger
again wait did he
did he manage what is going on so let's
see what happens so he went here so we
will go back to that game just very
curious what happens at the forest what
we're calculating King F4
and Rocket shade so if I go here why is
this a draw
because
um because why without the D and E pawns
it would just be losing right this is
lucina's
if I go here
so you have to defend your palm which
makes sense
[Music]
um
so
I want to go here so you don't get out
or so let's say here
Rook H3 only move I see according to the
table of pace what is what is Rook H3
about so it's just uh G2 then you take
take
or you can't take right like I think you
just lose if you take if you take
someone
no yeah yeah
can I go King F1
and then
oh man it's a very precise calculation
needed
and then this
oh but okay this is not hard to believe
right this thing is just on the other
side of the board
this is uh not very shocking to us uh
software update King went to H3 or KJ so
we're going to see all of this so let's
see we will see if Christopher you is
able to draw this which I think he
should be able to at this point right
because process of elimination he has a
lot of time so I think one of his
problems is when even when he has a lot
of time she doesn't spend the time like
that game against Mishra when I ask him
you're up an hour so did you think you
should have started something he was
like yeah I probably should have it's
like okay yeah maybe
uh so but I think he I think when he
sees something he just plays it he
doesn't question himself yeah he can
definitely relate to that style of play
no I'm the opposite I question myself
quite a bit so I'm on the other side of
it with always being in time travel
and so let's go back to Felix versus
Jason and we have a lot of moves coming
in
oh very close to what we're looking at
so we saw this bishop 127 I took
King took and the king is going from the
other side is going for this Pawn so
he's trying everything possible so his
idea is to take this pawn and let's say
how can I attack this plant from D5
right so let's say I go to but again
it's a night nights just get dominated
but I think every every single day it's
uh Knights versus nights versus Bishops
but here's it it's okay
no but did I find it
oh King City
uh yeah and if Keenan
can be two or oh
yeah we are in time and I think we
managed not to lose
for example even here what did I do so
like if I start pushing can you take and
I push
you actually have to worry about
stopping my Pawn right
yeah so something like B5 F6 and your
your claim is I need to play Bishop B8
otherwise I will lose and then I can
come and
table base tells us but
yeah but why would why would we risk
such a thing I think that this is
playing with fire yeah for sure but okay
here I think it's actually simple
because of this Knight C4 so for example
even something like this 54 I can just
take it oh yeah yeah
this is one of the first time games uh I
learned in chess
so this is an important end game to know
I think if you're a beginner
under a thousand you just need to be
able to draw our windows and games just
in your sleep
so he goes 95 and what is the idea after
King A4
because this is not
um
oh no this is what we're looking at
right we're looking at King A4 and 90.
yeah we were looking at Candy 293 yeah
so he won 95 immediately so what's the
idea here maybe he just wants to push
his Pawn now
F4 because it takes F5
so now I'm threatening this so it's very
similar and then Knight C4 here instead
yeah so instead you have to play here F6
which
I think this feels like a 97 Knight D7
of it
I can still lose why is there always a
trick
tells us you're not losing but why not
that is a good question aren't we losing
here
so it says King D3 but why not try
can get two
here it's important to leave the Knight
on B6 ah you just so you have this
Knight
I cannot pass I don't have a good way of
passing okay here you just put a kingdom
C1 and we're safe yeah but let's avoid
adventurous so 95 and King A4
so we went F4
King gate three all of this very forced
so F6 with this idea of
um
night C4 so we went King B3 F6 here so I
wonder if this is easier
so here
is this easier
tonight here
it's a C3 ah C3 we already forced to
draw or
am I re hallucinating here
if you go here
so I wanted to do this but I'm not in
time because King Victory and I cannot
get close to the pawn but maybe I have
92 and King D2 because here no you do
actually get there in time and
I'm threatening both this and this and
you cannot start both of these moves
okay we have moves we have Bishop A6
f
yeah white has already played F4 I
believe yeah F4 played
and if King here but not there's Knight
D7
or at least or I can also do this right
if you take now Knight
wait no now we have six there's no
Bishop C4
so Bishop C8 Knight C4 was was played so
King B5 is not a move
um
E5 runs into 90
night King A6 only move King A4 just
loses everything
Bishop basics
the players I've been playing for almost
five hours so I'm sure they're very
tired and Jason has less than two
minutes so
A6 was played but uh not Knight D6 right
now white gets the better version of
this
where do you go
yeah I actually have a hard time
imagining white loses this position
anymore because it seems like you should
be in time to even like
um I was thinking instead of F6 even you
could go like King C3 oh King D2 C3 and
I don't imagine you lose I just wanted
to find the palm
probably you're just going to win this
bishop right yeah and I shouldn't win
because you'll go B5 before so this
actually forces a draw
okay we're not gonna I'm not gonna say
anything every time I say something
bad really happened so commentator is
cursed so just let them
play this art but look
look I've also came
to King x96 I think is a very easy move
to play because
you're just attacking the bishop
clearing the path of the pawn but at the
same time maybe when King D2 is possible
because King p7 can I do this this must
be
four oh yeah before A4 is nice I think
A4 you have to play though like if you
don't play A4 then I think you lose to
B5 so if I go let's say here it yeah I
think this is hard right no because I
have I learned about summer all about
it's gonna be fun but I have to be
pretty okay if I go A4 here I will lose
of course but I will start with King P3
here I have four and if you go here
now I will win
so here you will have to take you go
after my Pawn I go after yours and
just trade everyone
okay so Knight C4 King A6 and no moves
yet Felix has quite a bit of time maybe
he's trying to be as precise as possible
he has a few options here King D2 might
just be the easiest move
yeah I'm always really scared to play
any sort of Keenan pot ending because if
I'm wrong then the game is just over and
uh I don't know it feels like right now
we don't we don't need to do we don't
need to do that
games are very uh you have to be very
certain that what you're doing is
correct because they're very precise you
can calculate them until the end which
is good because you can force your play
but also you have to make sure you're
not missing something because if you're
playing some kind of a
Rook end game where you're defending and
then you trade to even if let's say
you're up a pawn you trade down you give
up your Pawn to King and pawn and game
you might be losing you might be winning
and on the other hand you win a pawn you
might be losing yeah
the kingdom Pond Indians are are always
really really tricky even when they when
they don't seem like they're the case
that's the case
wait what
I just said oh sorry again um
there's too many arrows here so even 96
which I think is the most natural Tempo
move so the bishop if the bishop goes
here I think this is actually tricky
because now I'm threatening F6 F7 right
or maybe your Bishop gets dominated
Bishop being dominated that doesn't
sound like this tournament they're
definitely not so here I have this
okay nice yeah
it can be very fancy
this has to be
there's just nothing here I think before
and
you have B5 we can even play uh Knight
B5 yeah
very nice
so Bishop D7 was played
that's not good he's playing what I'm
predicting cannot be good so white ah
white plays King D2 I think white just
wants to be safe
and if King A5 I think King C3
and if here then Knight C4 I think is
also
oh yeah this is also probably just
making a draw by force because B5 U have
Knight B6 again
yeah
it would be very unfortunate if we don't
expect this to happen
and uh in group a savian so we learned
that uh Benjamin Baguio and Savion oh
well game but this must be
already a very easy draw so we can see
how we got here
so Rook 128
Chris Christopher is playing some very
precise defense here and very quickly
too because he has half an hour
and because the king is informed upon
any kind of queen traits would lead to a
draw we are in move 95 and they have
been playing for five hours and almost
100 moves so this is a big battle
what a game this round everybody
everybody's fighting their hardest and
um
they're playing very very long end games
which uh
uh yeah um well we'll put certain people
um
like a seven would have really liked to
win the sun game but Christopher is
defended really well
um why don't we go ahead and take a look
at the standings
um because we've more or less looked at
uh every game
um in the a group Benjamin Ghidorah and
Benjamin block have tied for first
um and we are awaiting the results of uh
Sam savian and Christopher you which
means we expect Christopher to join uh
Benjamin and Ghidorah for a tie for
first and in the B group
we are expecting uh Felix blauberger to
draw his game and remain a point ahead
of the field but uh it's not final and
it is possible that any one of those
players could could mess up that game in
some way still so
um
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
parents Port tomorrow though
um illy and nishnik will be playing
against nordebec yakubayov Darius
Schwartz against Daniel uh darha
Benjamin Bach against Benjamin Ghidorah
Sam sebian against ABI monumentra and
Yasser quesada Perez against Christopher
U
in group b it'll be Jason Leon Victor
man uh versus Victor mikhilevsky Dom
desarin for oh okay actually we have we
have gone to results so Felix blubberger
did uh draw his game against uh Jason
Liang which means he will be a point
ahead of Jason going into the final
round meaning that Jason needs to win in
order to tie for first so Felix can
secure the tournament tomorrow with a
draw a big big result for him I'm sure
he's relived and you know they're
playing those long games which makes me
wonder if they're not that too far the
Run starts two hours earlier because
they won't get as much time to prepare
and interesting you mentioned that Jason
is playing because tomorrow and we know
that michalevsky is uh
uh the most combative player here he has
five decisive results and he has been
playing this English line with black at
least when he faces the English right
this line with uh where he goes E5 and
sacrifices his line so I'm wondering if
Jason is going to look at that game and
be like oh he's just keeps playing this
in the tournament and try to repeat it
and try to find some kind of an
improvement and put some pressure on him
and we also have a draw in the Savion
game as we were expecting I click Miss
clicked a very nice game so this section
is over a group a is done and in Group B
I believe we only have
one more game going Victor Michales is
actually going to be losing his game so
this will be his six decisive results
not the result he wanted
but uh tomorrow he will be will he will
have to face
Jason Liang with the black pieces and
Jason is going to try to do everything
he can to win his game and of course
Felix can just clinch the tournament
with a draw so tomorrow is a big big day
and we will be crowning our champions
so let's go ahead and talk about
tomorrow there will be a lecture oh
sorry my bad tonight in half an hour
version of kovian will be giving a
lecture on Bobby Fisher so Bobby
Fisher's uh beautiful games against
um uh mihail tall and a um and some of
his games in the world championship I
believe and that will be on the World
Chess Hall of fault World Chess hall of
fames YouTube channel join us in half an
hour barakobian will be looking at some
of Bobby Fischer's games and make sure
you're joining us tomorrow
until we have a winner involved sections
so in case there is a time we'll bet we
will have a playoff and a tie break and
we'll be here for all of that so thank
you for joining us and make sure you're
tuning in tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited